[Music]
in wild night news submitted by swag jag
happily exhausted cat had to get a
glucose IV drip after mating with five
females in one night what a pip ass cat
so glucose like gives all for energy
yeah like a nutrition type drip some
different energy wait so what you saying
that if like he's [ __ ] exhausted is
what they're saying but I'm saying for
us applicable yeah if we ever get
exhausted he's trying to figure out how
he could replenish his [ __ ] and bad
luck drive three more rounds if I'm like
glucose yeah we're good again just make
it easier there self taking energy drink
or something yeah it's just sugar right
yeah that why you're constantly drinking
you're monsters of course always it on
the calendar
that you have to have sex today we're
doing for [ __ ] you have a sex
calendar you're kind of oh yeah exactly
in the land of she's not taking birth
control you better have his ex calendar
they're trying to have babies oh no
we're trying not to have babies right
now but but like for like I gotta know a
couple months maybe oh so you're trying
to avoid certain days yeah yeah yeah now
I am I'm going right away I don't think
you need it really I think it's the girl
needs it babe it's my day
come on alright so this cat here it's a
Russian Blue cat from South China Russia
some Russian is it an evergreen cat I
don't know what's funny yeah I know
she'll pee geraldine is a cat's name
always cute it looks like your guys are
kept for yeah yeah I think you know
those guys look like they're always full
of dust yeah
in a vacuum reversal but he's given like
this the [ __ ] boy look grumpy cat died
legit Nikki told you this boy yeah
exactly
the moral thing at the cat thing that
you go to the banquet they did everyone
looked grumpy for a second together you
look happy dude they say like yeah kind
of yeah that's pretty good actually
how long do cats live for ages dude wake
up the 20 years yeah no I think longer
they can have about a dog's life yeah
yours is almost like 25 or something
Oh human years yeah cuz I got him when
he was like 1 or 2 they live too long
and he's still [ __ ] alive and I got
him when I was like 19 dang that's an
old man thank you
so it's 17 oh that's all Oh about 22 or
something Roald Dahl's character why
don't you
I thought all this was like 30-something
that's nuts that's an old ass cat I
don't want to pet that long but I
thought grumpy cat was like on a thing
where they just kept on replacing the
cat and keep it like like Shamu Oh
grumpy cat has a lot I feel like they
like who's gonna be the next grumpy cat
you know they should Shamu grumpy
Kenneth smart idea I don't know Shamu
was replaced did yeah many times
I'll say jack [ __ ] that [ __ ] was dope I
like to get splashed by him those were
tears bro cuz he was sad
this [ __ ] will show sucks now [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
wait why there's still a well show think
they even took it out I heard they do
better tricks now come on they just do
that [ __ ] where they come up on and then
they do this and they go just go back
I'm like [ __ ] bad dude you know what
they used to do was they would [ __ ]
have the person on top and they would
[ __ ] jump out like this and you see
this big [ __ ] whale with the person
flipping and it'll splash I wish it
everybody her cilantro would get slashed
you wish that person got yes absolutely
oh come on he should have poor animals
oh you don't know what they what they
almost thinking
he's probably like oh he's having a
great time so the owner left this cat at
a pet hotel and was very clear Padma
tell my cat yeah they were very clear
that this cat is not been neutered watch
out he's horny yeah one of the workers
there ended up just letting all the cats
roam free so they could just go and i
employee went home so they were just out
of their cages orgy fest ah [ __ ]
everything the owner said that between
10:40 p.m. and 5 a.m. his cat mated with
five females and those are the only ones
that you could see from the CCTV footage
so there's more behind the scenes that's
a lot of calm stamina when cats [ __ ] did
he go in the position like a lion Fox
like the the chicks like just on the
bottom and then the guys on top or do
they focus that's doggy style
maybe but they're not all standing up oh
I don't know I'm asking is that what
happened turtle [ __ ] thing where
they're just laying down in the guys on
top of the other isn't that still just
doggy style no really yeah missionary
with this dog either standing up
well missionary they're laying down
that's your dog is the only animal
ending up so like this is one of them's
like this and then the other ones like
that oh that Bell yeah no right no no
the the turtle's legs are on the ground
yeah and then the other turtles on top
of the other so that's still kind of
doggy style isn't it no they're standing
up is doggy style like the way dogs till
a goddess kitty stop doggy so is you
laying on your belly while getting taken
from behind that's not dog hot dog
that's call froggy style that could be
frog that could be frog you stuff no dad
that's not what I made up you that's one
of my favorite positions I type it in
and I look for that specifically it's
called froggy style see basically it's
like Shamu style where he goes up on the
thing he's like make it personal purple
boggy style so anyway I mean this owner
said my [ __ ] cat is exhausted and on
his glucose drip and this is my fault
because uh the employees at the pet
hotel said that like they were upset
with the owner and saying that the owner
had to explain the situation to all
these I like that when this owners like
what the [ __ ] you're the one that left
and I told you it wasn't neutered
eventually the pet hotel apologized and
offered to pay for the fluid therapy and
then said that they were going to
compensate each pregnant cats owners if
they end up being pregnant and then he
[Music]
hey what happened we could hear it that
sounds like porn that was camera porn
for sure I know that I'm sticking my
thumb up there hold on but I don't think
it was plugged in you Japanese pervert
so the pet hotel said that they were
going to compensate each pregnant cats
owner
I heard compensate compensate yeah and
then they said that they have promised
that they would be responsible for
selling any kitties that come out of
this better she do pass and then this
cat's owner said that the other owners
have also told him that they will either
give him a kitty or give him a thousand
yuan because these Russian blue cats are
really really sought after and really
expensive they're pure or not if they're
well yeah a pedigree one yeah they're
mixed okay guys you yeah you I'm talking
to you right now listen to me if you
haven't subscribe make sure to subscribe
right now we're gonna wait if you want
to be as horny as this cat you better
hit that subscribe button it's gonna
help you up with that vitality yeah okay
we're done waiting thanks for subscribe
I feel like this cat's pretty happy
though your tables over the bone five
other chicks oh yeah I'm sure the other
photo I just showed you the first one
who said their chicks they're Katie's oh
she does believe this face Wow coal
mines this is pre sex
so she could be his own face - I love
when they sleep like that
ah cat sleep like that
did you never seen a cat [ __ ] five times
that's true
is this normal like your cat or cats
this morning I heard cats [ __ ] a lot
when I lived in this uh apartment the
head yeah I thought they were fighting
all the time yeah yeah I thought they
were just like having [ __ ] cat fights
you know like [ __ ] at night it's like
well then it was like people like no
that's them [ __ ] it yeah my sister
Mexico I remember she told me cuz there
were so many cat and like my grandma's
house they would be [ __ ] all the time
like damn they're brawling a lot she's
like oh yeah that's what she said and
then that's when she told me that like
cat penises have like thorns and Emerson
yeah watch why would they [ __ ] the
pretty [ __ ] hook in there maybe cuz
it's rape girl we gotta fight for these
female cats
there you go oh right yeah this is this
was consensual I don't think so
if there's spikes on the guy's dick I
don't want it mm-hmm when I lived in
Escondido I used to hear those noises
and I thought it was cats [ __ ] but I
found out that it was just coyotes
ripping cats apart oh I've heard of that
coyote sound crazy nuts when they travel
in their pockets really always killing
some [ __ ] yeah because we live right by
the mountains yeah it sounds like
imagine two little dogs fighting each
other and like to the death that's what
it sounds like yeah when they're
together and they're hunting and there
are they just got a kill it's like
pretty nuts yeah but they're like
screeching like high pitch it's not like
like a base you growing like wolf sounds
like a alpha animal in the forest yeah
the Coyotes they sound like scoundrels
yeah they say yeah yeah like the hyenas
of the dogs yeah like just selling used
cars and [ __ ] woods yeah yeah yeah
gyah what is the fish there boo that's
really good once again
knowing each animal sounds oh how do you
not know this she has been drilling them
on top of the key have I not impressed
you give me another one
all right um Mongoose Oh problem [ __ ]
you got me meerkat did they make no I
saw the important yeah
the oppression okay I've done you guys
shall we do a lot of animal watching
yeah aren't you happy a subscribe
hippopotamus II importable Potamus
platypus platypus the platypus says let
me die here look to one of those [ __ ]
I want a manatee for a pair we're not
even talking about what you want for
peds bro I know but I just wanna
[Music]